Well, good morning to you. I trust your
enjoying the cooler weather this morning kind of nice wouldn't it?
Love this time of year.
If you have your Bibles with you, we're going to be in Psalm 51
today.
Taking a break from our study in Micah.
If you are new to Henderson Hills, my name is Aaron Ferguson.
I'm one of the elders here.
And it's my pleasure to study Psalm 51 with
you this morning.
I must admit. I'm a little uncomfortable teaching behind
a table. I usually like to have a Podium or something I
can stand behind.
Especially after what happened to me just a few weeks ago.
I got home after church and the
Fly was open.
Yeah.
How many is that happened to in here?
Oh, I'm the only one. Okay. Well you guys
are lying.
So mad at myself.
The problem was I had been with people all morning
and nobody said a thing.
I'd even stood down here to pray
with people. No one approached me and now I
know why.
You know scared to death to see that down there,
but I was so mad at myself. I got home. I you know
for guys an open fly is like rookie mistake.
I thought I had mastered that technique and anyway through
the jeans in the closet. I was
so mad at myself.
But I didn't think anything about about it until a few days later. Wednesday night
was church. I put the same jeans back on I come
through the back door. The auditorium did a
quick check.
My Zipper was down again second time.
Now I start to go and fix the problem. But as
soon as I did a church member walks up with a question.
Yeah.
And so what do you do in that moment? I'm just
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
awkward three minutes there
ran back into the bathroom fixed the problem came back in
and as we sat and stood in the church service my zipper
made its way down again third time. That's
when it dawned on me.
I am not the problem here. There's a design flaw.
in the genes
So I got home. I wanted to throw those jeans on my grill
and light them on fire, but
I didn't do that. I threw him in the Donate pile and they're going to
be someone else's problem.
So if you shop at thrift stores and you
just recently purchased some jeans you might want to check your
zipper.
So that's why I like to stand behind something.
Well, that's probably more than you wanted to know about me this
morning, but I am teaching about transparency and
confession.
Which is just openly admitting your shame and that's what
David is going to do in Psalm 51 this
morning.
And so if you have your Bibles there will be in just
a minute in Psalm. 51 Psalms are
just songs.
Just poems put to music. There's 150
of them. We know that it's taken us what three years
to get to Psalm 51.
But we know David has written 75 of
them at least and they're just transparent looks at
his life from the highest of highs to
the lowest of lows, which is Psalm
51 now.
Psalm 51 is very similar to six other what's called
penitent Psalms.
And I've listed there them for you on your notes at the top there. I
would encourage you to read the penitent Psalms sometime this
week and just compare them to
Psalm 51.
Now, what does it mean to be penitent? We don't use that word a
lot. It just means to express.
Sorrow for sin or guilt.
And that's what David is going to do here in Psalm 51,
raise your hand if you've ever sinned and needed forgiveness.
Yeah, everybody's hand should be up. We all are broken
people and we need forgiveness. What
do you do when you sin and you?
You mess up you offend god with something you've
done. Well, you cry out to God and penitent.
prayer
well before we dive into Psalm 51, I want to look at the context what
was happening in David's life that he wrote this
what was what was great sin in
his life prompted Psalm 51, and so
There should be at the top of your Psalm a little introduction to
the psalm. If not, this is what mine says.
Psalm of David when Nathan the prophet came to
him
After he had gone into or committed adultery
with Bathsheba.
There it is. He gives us the context.
For Psalm 51 adultery with Bathsheba now.
I appreciate that. He said that but he's
not telling the whole story.
And so I do think we could learn a little bit more
if we saw the whole story. So keep your finger
in Psalm 51, if you would let's go to Psalm. Excuse
me. Second Samuel chapter 11.
Let's find out what the rest of the story is here adultery with
Bathsheba is just the beginning.
second Samuel chapter 11
if you like to connect passages, I would encourage you to
There in Psalm 51 to write second Samuel 11 and
when you get to second Samuel 11, you might write Psalm 51.
This is the backdrop for Psalm 51.
second Samuel chapter 11 verse 1
in the spring of the year the time when kings go out
to battle David sent joab that's his military leader.
And his servants with him and all Israel and they ravaged the
ammonites and besieged rabba.
But David remained at Jerusalem.
Now here's his first problem. He's all alone. He's not
where he should be should be with his men.
in battle
verse 2. It happened late one afternoon. When David arose from
his couch was walking on the roof of the King's house.
That he saw from a roof from the roof a
woman bathing in the woman was very beautiful.
And David sent an inquired about the woman and one
said is this not Bathsheba the daughter of a lion the
wife of Uriah the hittite.
Now time out. That's David's out right there. This is
a red flag. This lady is married.
you know, the Bible tells us God will not allow us to be tempted beyond
what we are able but with the Temptation he
provides a way of
Escape here's David's Escape. He didn't take
it.
So what does he do verse 4 David sent Messengers and
took her?
And she came to him and he lay with her.
And then she returned to her house and the woman conceived and she
sent and told David I'm pregnant.
Oh, so the adultery now has a consequence.
And what does David going to do next verse 6 David sent
word to joab?
Send Me Uriah the hittite and Joe absent Uriah to
David and when Uriah came to him David asked how Joad was
doing how the people were doing how the war was going?
And David said to Uriah go down to your house and wash your
feet now that's code for go spend time at
home with your wife. He was trying to cover his tracks.
But verse 9 Uriah slept at the door of the King's house
with all the Servants of his Lord and did not go down to his house.
And when they told David Uriah did not go down to his house. David
said to Uriah have you not come from a journey? Why did you not go
down to your house? And Uriah said to David the ark?
That's the Ark of the Covenant.
and Israel and Judah dwell in booths
or tents
and my Lord joab and the Servants of my Lord are camping in the Open Fields.
Shall I then go to my house to eat and drink and
lie with my wife?
As you live, I will not do this thing. He's an
honorable man, and this has to just be burning David.
Inside here that he won't go home to be with his
wife. So David said to Uriah remain
here today also and tomorrow I will
send you back and so Uriah remained in Jerusalem that
day in the next.
And David invited him and he ate in his presence
and drank and so that he made him drunk again. He's trying
to cover his tracks. He's trying to
to get your riots to go home to be with
his wife.
In the evening, he went out to lie on his couch with the Servants
of his Lord. He did not go down to his house. He's an honorable
man.
And in the morning David wrote a letter to joab and
sent it by the hand of your right.
In the letter, he wrote Set Uriah in the Forefront
of the hardest fighting then draw back
from him that he may be struck down and die.
All right, he's crossed another line here and he's ordered the
murder of this innocent man. Skip
on down to verse 26 when the
wife of Uriah heard that Uriah her
husband was dead. She lamented over her husband.
And when the morning was over David sent and brought her to
his house and she became his wife and bore him a son.
Hopefully again trying to cover his tracks and
cover up the pregnancy.
He thought he had got away with it. But it says this the thing that
David did had
displeased the Lord
Well what happens next God sends a prophet Nathan to
David if you'll turn to chapter 12 just verse
1.
The Lord sent Nathan to David. He tells him a story
to sort of appeal to his conscience brick his
conscience.
The story was about a rich man who stole a
poor man's land.
skip down to verse 5
David's anger was greatly kindled against
the man.
And he said to Nathan as the Lord lives the man who
has done this deserves to die.
And he shall restore the lamb forefold because
he did this thing and because he had no pity.
And Nathan looks at David says to David you are
the man.
this had to just
smack David in the nose
Thus says the Lord the god of Israel. I anointed you King over
Israel. I delivered you out of the hand of Saul. Why
have you despise the word of the Lord to
do what's evil in his sight?
You have struck down Uriah the
hittite with the sword and have taken his wife
to be your wife.
And then in verse 13 David says to Nathan I
have sinned against the Lord.
This is the context of Psalm 51. Finally
David sees he has
Done what's evil in the side of the Lord, you know before we go back
to Psalm 51. I think there's some good observations we can make
from this story.
Just about our own sin. And I think it's going
to help us to understand or appreciate Psalm 51
even more. So, let me just make a few brief observations about
Sin from the context here in
second Samuel number one. No one is
without sin.
No one is without sin. You
all raised your hand just a minute ago. We've all been
there.
No one is without sin not Kings. Not you
not even me.
Everyone is capable of terrible wrongdoing.
No matter who we are and I love that about the Bible. It
does not gloss over.
You know, this is a superhero in the Bible David
and look what he's done. The Bible is very
transparent with his life.
No one is without sin number two.
While you and I think that our sin may
be hidden the truth is God knows it.
God knows it and he will bring it to light.
Now you may be able to fool other people and you
may even be able to fool yourself, but you cannot fool God.
God knows what you're doing.
Or what you have done.
number three
when we or I tolerate one
sin.
We just open the door to other sins.
David lusted after Bathsheba. He
coveted another man's wife committed adultery.
He tolerated those sins and
as a result, he ends up committing other sins
to hide that sin. It just turns into a sin snowball.
And that's the way it usually works with sin.
When you tolerate one, it just opens the door to others.
The fourth observation is this I can easily identify other
sins, but I'm often blind to
my own.
David spots the the evil of the man's action.
in Nathan's parable
But he couldn't even see his own actions as evil.
We can easily spot other people's sins. We were sometimes blinds
who our own.
Fifth observation is this my sin
always affects other
people.
My sin always affects other people. Sometimes we
think I'm not hurting anybody.
With what I'm doing I'm sinning. I know it
but I'm not hurting anybody else. That is untrue.
David's sin hurt a lot of people here Bathsheba
the child that
is going to be the result of this adulterous Affair.
He affected joab Uriah is
dead.
The ammonites his family. We're going to see even affects all
the whole Kingdom of Israel.
Your sin does not just affect you. It's
like a ripple effect that affects everyone around you
whether you know it or not whether you believe it or not.
The six observation is this while God forgives me?
Of my sin. He still allows me to experience the
consequences.
David is going to be forgiven.
But he condemns the man in the story that Nathan told
fourfold that man should pay fourfold. You
know, what happens today, but you keep reading the story.
He loses four Sons.
God allowed him to experience the consequences of
his sin, even though he forgave David of his
sin.
That's what I mean by there's much more to the story than what David writes
here.
Adultery with Bathsheba. There's a lot
going on here, and he has sinned greatly. Let's go
back to Psalm 51.
What David has done obviously is awful.
The Lord calls it evil.
But before you and I Judge Too, harshly
we have to point those same fingers back at ourself.
Every one of us is capable of terrible
wrongdoing just like David.
Now you say I haven't committed adultery. I
haven't murdered anyone, but you know what?
Our sins are just as odious in the eyes of God as
David sins and gee, you
know, Jesus equates lusting after people.
with adultery in your heart
pornography is a plague on
this country. We are committing adultery in
our hearts, even though you may not carry
out the physical.
adulterous relationship
Jesus even relates anger and hatred
for someone to murder
ever hated someone ever wished them evil. Wish
them wrong.
What about lying stealing?
cheating
worshiping people other than God
Dishonoring your parents coveting Pride greed.
Jealousy Envy
Drunkenness, foul language, I mean I could
list a page of sins. We've
all been there. We've all committed these same
things that David has done. So let's
not judge him too. Harshly. We're in the same boat with him.
But what do we do? We're just as rotten as
David. What do we do?
I've got good news for you. This might be the most important thing. I tell
you this morning God receives sinners.
God receives sinners
He is Holy. He is perfect. He's pure
he's all good. He can do no wrong.
You and I are very much otherwise.
We are none of those things and you know that and yet
God receives sinners.
There's this huge gap between us but he receives us. What does that
mean? We have an audience with
the creator of Heaven and Earth we have an audience with
The only moral being in the
universe he is willing to listen to us
night or day.
He receives Sinners what? Okay, so what do we do?
We pour out our heart to God like Dave it's
going to do in Psalm 51.
We cry out to God and penitent prayer. So let's do
that. Let's just read verse by verse Psalm 51
and let's see what David does here.
I wish there were.
There was more organization to this Psalm really
struggled with.
How do we proceed?
Through Psalm 51 he there is no organization
to this Psalm. I what I'm about to share with you is
just kind of what I see him doing but
He just lays it all out there transparent confession.
He just pours his heart out to
God, but I think we can make some sense out of what he does.
First thing he does is plead for mercy.
Plead for Mercy verse 1.
Have mercy on me o God, according to
your steadfast love according to
your abundant Mercy blot out my transgressions. He
just pleads for mercy.
You know as Sinners we deserve God's Wrath.
We deserve God's judgment. We deserve the consequences that
are coming to us.
We deserve eternity in Hell separated from
him.
We know that.
But praise God, he's a god of
abundant Mercy. He doesn't give us what we deserve.
That's what David is saying have mercy on me.
Oh God. What? Why doesn't he give us what we deserve because
of his steadfast love he
loves you.
He wants a relationship with you.
He sent his son to pay the penalty for
your sin. He loves you that much.
God receives Sinners and he's merciful
to us just cry out
to God and plead.
For his Mercy there is hope for Sinners
because we have a merciful god.
He pleads for Mercy. What's the second thing? He does he
prays for forgiveness?
Naturally you offend god with your sin. You're going to pray for
forgiveness. Continue there in verse 1.
According to your abundant Mercy blot out
my transgressions Wash Me thoroughly from my iniquity.
Cleanse me from my sin.
three times in three different ways David asks
for forgiveness
I love that term blot out my transgressions. We
don't.
Quite understand that today we might say erase.
My transgressions hit the delete button.
On my transgressions, they didn't have erasers back then they didn't have delete
buttons.
What they had was ink.
And what he's doing is he's given a poetic picture
here of God is recording all of
your transgressions. He's got them written down.
God take your ink and just pour it
out over my transgression so you can't see.
the record of my wrongdoing anymore
blot out my transgressions Wash Me
thoroughly from my iniquity cleanse
me from my sin.
I love poetry.
He he's using transgression iniquity sin
kind of as the same thing, but there is a difference here.
Sin has to do with our actions Lord cleanse me
from my actions remove them from your memory
from my memory.
Cleanse me from my sin, but he uses the word iniquity
that has to do with who we are as a
person. We are depraved.
individuals rotten
corrupt
He uses the word wash me that word is scrub
me.
Make me a new person.
So blot out my transgressions just cover them
up.
Cleanse me from all my sinful actions just take
them away.
And wash me scrub my heart make me a new
person. I don't want to be a rotten person.
anymore
You know, it's important to note here. God is the only one who
can do these three things.
He's the only one that can do anything about your sin your
spouse can't help you your family can't help
you. Your friends. Can't help you your elders can't
help you with this.
You can't do anything about this only God
can
cleanse you from your sin. Go to God and penitent prayer.
That's what David is doing here. So he's pleading for Mercy. He's
praying for forgiveness. What's the third
thing? He does he confesses his sin and his
shortcomings.
He confesses his sin and his shortcomings verses 3 through 6.
He confesses his sin in his shortcomings sin
what we have done.
Shortcomings who I am as a person watch
the two in these verses
verse 3 for I know my transgressions. I
know what I've done.
My sin is ever before me.
It just weighs me down. It's on my mind
night and day what I've done wrong. He's confessing.
What he's done against you, I have sinned
and done. What is evil.
In your sight. He's confessing.
His sins his actions when he says I
know and I know what I've done he is.
You could say owning up to his.
Wrongdoing he's not blaming it on anyone else
but himself.
you ever done that blame your wrongdoing on
somebody else if they hadn't done that I wouldn't have done this or
Find a grown up this way. I wouldn't have acted that way. No, no.
You and I must take ownership of
our own sin and not blame it on
anyone or anything. That's what David is doing
here.
verse 4
God you are you may be justified in your
words blameless in your judgment.
But behold, I was brought forth and iniquity and in
sin did my mother conceive me?
Behold you Delight in truth in the
inward being inside of me and you
teach me wisdom in the secret heart. What David is
doing here is he's comparing himself to God God you are
just you are blameless you Delight
in truth and wisdom, and I'm none of
those things.
God you are up here and I am down here behold.
I was brought forth in iniquity in sinned
in my mother conceived me. I've been rotten since
birth.
God you are this and I am this.
confess
The great gap between you and God I have nothing
I can bring you nothing Lord.
I'm rotten.
I'm sinful. I'm ashamed.
and what I've done
I love again the transparency of
the Bible David defeated Giants.
David defeats all of his enemies on the battlefield, but
he can't defeat his own sinful nature.
Only God can do that.
God you're up here. I'm down here. I am nothing.
I've defeated Giants. I'm nothing.
I have defeated all my enemies and yet I'm still nothing compared to
you.
See yourself for who you are in light of
who God is confess your sin
in shortcomings.
What's the next thing David does here pleads for
Mercy he prays for forgiveness. He confessed
his sin in shortcomings. Now, he kind of turns the
corner a little bit and he professes his desire to be restored.
God I want to be restored. I want to be a
new person.
Watch how he says this verses 7 through 12.
Purge me he says with hyssop
and I shall be clean his hip is
a plant in the Old Testament
that they used as a paintbrush.
You remember when they applied the blood over the doorpost in
Egypt that was with hyssop the paintbrush?
And later priests would use it to sprinkle you with blood.
When you made a covenant.
When you were being forgiven of your sin, Lord?
Sprinkle me with blood Purge me and make
me clean. That's the picture. He's given us here.
Wash me and I shall be whiter than snow.
Let me hear joy and gladness.
Let the bones that you have broken.
Rejoice these are all poetic terms. Let me
You have broken my bones. I feel the weight of
my sin God. I want to be.
I want to experience that. Joy and gladness again.
Hide your face from my sins blot out
my iniquities.
Create in me a clean heart. Oh God renew or
right Spirit within me. I want to
be a new person.
I don't want to do this again.
skip down to verse 12
restore to me the joy of your salvation uphold
me with a willing spirit.
You know unconfessed sin you let sin
go on and you tolerate it in your life. It just
begins to weigh you down.
It steals your joy.
Takes away your happiness your your gladness.
He says it makes you feel like
you're crippled. You got so much weight and Stress
and Anxiety on you. You just you cripple
yourself. My bones are broken.
How do we
how do we free ourselves from that we we confess
all these things?
And we say Lord. I want to be a new person again, please
please help me.
Just feel David sincere plea for
help here.
Let's skip verse 11 for a reason.
Let's go back to verse 11 cast me not away from your presence take not
your Holy Spirit from me.
David you can tell it's very concerned about losing
the spirit.
If you know the story of King Saul King Saul had the spirit
of God on him and later. God took it from him.
In the Old Testament, we see the spirit.
Indwelling people throughout the Bible, but it's
temporary.
Kind of jumps from here to there.
This is much different in the Old Testament than it is. The New Testament. David's
concerned that the same thing that happened to Saul is
going to happen to him. God, please.
Don't take your Holy Spirit from me like you did with
King Saul don't cast me away from your presence. I
still want to be useful.
to you
now, please hear this you and I in the
New Testament the Holy Spirit indwells us
permanently.
John Chapter 14 verse 16
Christ is leaving. He sends the helper.
To indwell us forever. He says
you and I don't have to worry about verse 11. Nothing
can separate you from the love of
God. You have the Holy Spirit in you
permanently. So we don't have to worry
about that. But our fellowship with God has been
broken by our sin and God seems distant
to us, even though he's right there. He seems distant because
we have hindered our fellowship with him because
of our sin.
What's the fifth thing David does here?
He expresses his repentance.
Repentance is just a change.
a change in heart a change in Attitude a change
in actions you're going one way when you repent
you turn around and go completely the opposite way and I'll
just be honest with you if you
Pray, a prayer of forgiveness without repentance.
You're just saying a bunch of words.
You're basically saying God, excuse me, instead of
God, forgive me. Excuse me, God I'm going
to do this again. I know.
Wait, wait, we have to have repentance.
As a part of our prayer God, I
don't want to go down the same road again. I want to
go down a different Road. I want to be a different person. I don't
want to do that again.
It's not excuse me. It's
forgive me repentance. I'm going to change.
So notice how David changes he begins
to see life on the other side of forgiveness.
Look at verse 13 through 17. Then
I will teach transgressors your
ways and sinners will return to
you.
Deliver me from blood guiltiness o God of my salvation.
And my tongue will sing aloud at your righteousness.
Lord open my lips and my mouth will declare your praise
David wants to use his
failure as a way to glorify God after
the Forgiveness after the restoration
Aren't you glad God uses imperfect people to do his work?
He's the god of Second Chances third chances
fourth chances if he just used Perfect People
you and I would never get a chance to be used by
God.
But he doesn't do that.
Whatever. God has saved you from whatever God
has done in your life use it to tell other people. I
was rotten.
And I'm still rotten except for Christ.
And here's what he's done in my life. He can do the same thing for you. That's
what David is saying.
I will teach transgressors your ways.
I'm gonna change the direction of my life.
verse 16
for you will not Delight in sacrifice, or I would
give it.
You will not be pleased with a burnt offering.
The sacrifices of God are a broken
spirit and a broken and contrite heart o God,
you will not despise.
What he's talking about here is a change in his
worship.
If you carry sin in here and you never
let God deal with it.
You and I are just going through the motions saying the
words.
We're here because this is what we do on Sunday.
God
is he doesn't want you just to go through the motions. He wants
to deal with your sin what you're doing.
He wants to restore that relationship between you and he
In other words he wants to you to be broken.
And contrite the word contrite here is humble.
Be humbled before the Lord.
Let him deal with what you've done let him
deal with who you are.
Don't come in and out of here and not leave restored
in your relationship with
the Lord. Otherwise, you're just going through the motions.
rituals
so just what we do and David saying
I would give you a sacrifice, but you wouldn't take it.
Does he not like sacrifices? Yes, he does. It's a
sign of worship, but it's just going through the
motions unless you repent of what you've done and
you come to God with a broken and humble spirit.
How's your worship been?
Is it cold?
and distant
is it sincere?
and genuine
and humble and broken
can tell where you're at with the Lord just by
gauging your worship.
finally
David ends 18 and 19. He asked God
the bless others despite his sin
remember?
Sin is a ripple effect. We affect others
with our sin whether we know it or not, whether we
believe that or not and he's concerned that he has affected.
The nation as a whole because the King has done what
he's done. The nation is not going to be
Blessed so look at Verse 18.
Do good to Zion in your good pleasure.
Don't?
Base your favor on God's people he says.
because of me
Please do good.
To Zion to Jerusalem build up the walls of Jerusalem. Then
you will Delight in right sacrifices and
burn offerings whole burn offerings and
Bulls will be offered on your altar again.
He's talking about worship. Don't allow what
I've done to hinder your favor on others.
This is just a
a heartfelt sincere
cry out to the Lord
penitent prayer
God receives sinners
and I got better news God redeems.
sinners
how do we know that?
We are forgiven when we confess our sins like David has
done listen to First John 1:9.
You're familiar with this.
If we confess our sins, he is faithful and righteous to
forgive us our sins and to cleanse
us from all unrighteousness if we
confess.
repent
or humble before the Lord transparent
He's faithful to forgive us and cleanse us
from all unrighteousness. If you back up to verse 7, he
says this the very end the blood of
Jesus is what cleanses all sins.
Listen, it's not David's prayer.
That forgave David there's no.
There's no formula. There's no right words.
That you have to say.
For God to forgive you David was forgiven because
God is merciful.
And God forgives and he loves.
us
and he forgave David because of Christ.
The same is for you you and I there's no certain words.
There's no formula. We just
throw ourselves before a merciful god and say
I am rotten.
But because of Christ I'm asking that you forgive me
blot out my sins.
Purge my heart
Scrub me.
Make me new because of Christ we know.
that God forgives us because of our
sincere confession
I want to ask you a question as we close.
Gonna do something a little different today.
I just want to ask you are you aware of the sin in
your life today right now?
Are you aware?
Of the ways that you are offending God.
Those of you are not Christians you don't know.
Christ as your savior
one of these days you're going to have to stand before God and
answer for your sins.
And without Christ that picture is not going to
be pretty.
You will spend eternity separated from God.
Don't leave here today and be our prayer
that you come to Christ.
And you know him as your savior.
I realize most of you though have given your life to
Christ. Are you aware of the sin in your life
and how it has?
Broken your fellowship with him.
You don't lose your salvation because you sin your sin
is Forgiven past present and future. We know that.
But your fellowship with God may be hindered.
broken clouded
can you hear God's voice right now in your life?
Are you sensitive to his Spirit? Can you?
discern his will
for your life
Are you experiencing the joy?
Of your salvation. If not, there's probably sin in
your life that you've not dealt with.
Don't leave here today.
Without dealing with your sin.
What are you hiding?
What are you ignoring?
What are you tolerating that you shouldn't be?
cry out to God
In penitent prayer he receives sinners.
And he redeems sinners.